guardians of the galaxy vol 2 marks the
first big-screen incarnation of Marvel
Comics character montes played by korean
french actress Tom Clement EF while she
was relatively unknown before landing
her big break in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there's still a chance you
might have seen Clemente F before he is
why mantas may have looked familiar
early years Clement EF gotta start on
camera fresh out of drama school and
independent French films her first
starring gig was in 2009 s wolf as a
Siberian reindeer herder she followed it
up with smaller roles over the next few
years and a wide variety of releases
including a string of parts in 2011 with
appearances in action thriller sleepless
nights and crime comedy borderline just
to name a few
we're good yet Clement EF also appeared
in 2012 gross old comedy porn in the
hood the most profitable French film of
the year old boy before landing the role
of Montes Clemens he has highest profile
performance by far was of The Bodyguard
in Spike Lee's 2013 remake of the 2003
South Korean thriller oldboy a very
physical role that required intense
training a fun of the original old boy
she wanted to make sure the fight scenes
are up to snuff and enjoyed a strict
regimen to prepare samargan euro lean
training martial arts three hours a day
for two month now as I said I love the
tournelle but after at the end of the
movie because I'm professional hackers
game after breaking out with old boy
Clementi have landed a starring role in
the widely panned 2015 mid budget
romantic thriller hackers game a
high-stakes relationship drama between
two high-level hackers 70s plays Louis
officially a cyber detective who falls
for an Edward Snowden like figure how
did right by us end up on your computer
for me the first film of Clementi asked
to give the actress top billing was also
her first major misstep with the Los
Angeles Times in particular throwing
some serious shade her way saying she
displayed the acting range of a petulant
child
Sundance star if you were fortunate
enough to attend the 2017 Sundance Film
Festival you may have seen Clement EF on
a few panels and into supporting roles
in films making their debut the social
media dating drama newness and the
social media stalking comedy ingrid goes
west
starring Aubrey Plaza which hits
theaters in August a look ahead we
already know Clement EF will be back in
2018 Avengers infinity war which brings
the Guardians face to face with the
Avengers and James Gunn hinted in a
Facebook post that she would be back for
confirmed to see caller guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 as well saying his love for
mantis under fellow Guardians goes
deeper than you guys can possibly
imagine you can just feel the love yes
yeah sure no no I don't know thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
what check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]